اقبال كبير مخالف للتوقعات في الايام
الاولى من معرض القاهره الدولي للكتاب
اكثر من مليون زائر تدفقوا الى المعرض في
ايامه الخمسه الاولى متحدين اجواء الشتاء
الممطر والاهم الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تمر
بها البلاد الجمهور لم يكتفي بحضور
الفعاليات والندوات بل زادت وبشكل ملحوظ
نسبه شراء الكتب رغم ارتفاع الاسعار بسبب
الازمه الاقتصاديه الواحد بيسيب نفسه بقى
المعرض فطبيعي اي حاجه بتعجبه بيجيبها
وبعد كده مش مشكله لو خربت الميزانيه
الكتاب بيبقى اهم دايما
طبعا عشان السعر بختار اهم حاجه منهم ممكن
اختار لو قدامي عشره ممكن اختار خمسه بس
مثلا
2000 جنيه او 3000 جنيه فكان ممكن هيجيبوا
له 100 كتاب دلوقتي هيجيبوله مثلا 50 او
60 كتاب كلمه السر وراء الاقبال كانت
التسهيلات والتقسيط والخصومات التي اسهمت
في زياده الاقبال على شراء الكتب خاصه من
دور النشر الحكوميه التي وفرت الكتب
باسعار زهيده بعكس بعض دور النشر الخاصه
التي لم تتمكن من تخفيض اسعارها الامر
الذي ادى لتباين معدلات البيع تدور النشر
تخفيضات وعروض مش هتبيع انا
شخصيا بايعه لا وكاتبها انا بقول لحضرتك
رحت ما لقيتش نسخ يعني هي خلصت في خلال
الكم يوم دول
المعرض الذي بدا عام 69 من القرن الماضي
يقام الان وسط ازمه اقتصاديه ادت لارتفاع
في اسعار السلع كافه ومن بينها الورق الذي
تستورد منه مصر نحو 3000 طن سنويا الورق
زاد بنسبه 3 اضعاف ومستلزمات الاخرى بنسبه
50% اقبال كبير خلف كل التوقعات هذا العام
من جمهور تحدى وتجاوز ازمه اقتصاديه هي
الاعنف في السنوات الاخيره ازمه انعكست في
موجه غلاء ضاعفت اسعار الكتب ثلاث مرات
على الاقل ولكنها لم تنتمي جمهور المعرض
عن القراءه راندا ابو العزم العربيه
القاهره